[Music]
Christian is in Chicago hi Christian
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show yeah
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up not much so I just want
to get your advice on something I
recently got a new job where I'm making
a lot better income than I used to and
my question is I rent I'm saving up for
a house I still live at home with my
parents you know I'm also investing very
heavily in the market so I just want to
get your opinion on what do you suggest
that I should uh more towards like
saving towards house or investing in the
market because right now I'm investing
way more in life than I am saving for a
house mm-hmm how old are you I'm on a 25
okay well I think your first goal is get
out of the house okay
that's maybe my first goal get out of
your parents house and then how much
money you making Oh
last year I made a hundred and
sixty-five thousand and you're hold 25
please yeah and and you have how much
more some basic debts I'm siding me to
cut you off that's right basic did I
just have my vehicle dead something that
I really don't have any debt off my
student loan this year mm-hmm okay how
much do you owe on your car oh about
thirty five thousand and how much do you
have in savings not counting retirement
eleven thousand that's what I was kind
of saving towards the house okay where
I'm at so far okay well I mean what I
would do and you can do whatever you
want to do but if I woke up in your
shoes my son is 26 and he's one of the
vice presidents company and he's just
got married this year and if he walked
in and gave me your exact situation
here's what I would do the first thing I
would tell him to do is move out and get
and get an apartment yesterday you're 25
years old you make 165 thousand dollars
you don't need to live with your mother
okay that's the first thing I would do
it's just a dignity thing man seriously
and and I would get that going and the
second thing I would do is I get this
car paid off as soon as possible
and I would use some of that eleven
thousand you only
some of it to move out and buy you a
couch and a TV and deposit on the
apartment and that kind of stuff get you
a little one-bedroom apartment or
whatever you get I don't care something
inexpensive don't spend a bunch of money
on rent but get out get on your own get
your own bill set up get things going
and I think then let's get the car paid
off then let's build an emergency fund
you don't need to be doing any investing
while you have a $35,000 car debt okay
so step one is to have at least a
thousand dollars after you're settled
into your apartment everything else goes
towards the car step two is we pay off
all debt which is your car in your case
you're gonna do that very fast because
you make a lot of money now baby step
number three then is you build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses in your case that's probably
fifteen thousand bucks okay okay and we
build that up we have fifteen thousand
dollars and zero debt and that covers
you if you have a little bump in the
road right as you're going along okay
now we're sitting in an apartment with
$15,000 and no debt that feels pretty
good doesn't it now we start saving for
a house if you want to save for a house
or you can start your investing one of
the two I don't care which one you do at
that point there's no rush to buy a
house you'll get around to buying one
and you probably should buy one sometime
in the next five years or so and that
may be when you meet that perfect
someone or it may be when you decide I'm
gonna be classically single I don't care
but but sometime in the next five years
or so I don't want you're renting long
long term and so you can start saving up
your down payment at that point above
your emergency fund and no more
borrowing and then you would start you
can start investing I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book the Total Money
Makeover which will walk you through
exactly what I just talked about we call
those the baby steps baby step one two
three four five six and seven
one is $1,000 two's debt free accept the
house you don't have a house so it's
debt-free three is an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses four is
when you start putting 15% of your
income away for retirement five is kids
college you skip that one
six is pay off the house early so baby
step three be between the
emergency fund and the investing is
where you would save for a house and
that's where a lot of people do all of
that is outlined in the Total Money
Makeover and I'll give you a copy as my
gift thanks for being a new listener sir